it goes along with my book which is
basically making the argument that
belief in non-human intelligence or ets
or ufos uaps whatever you want to call
them
is a new form of religion and
how does that work with the the
scientific method
do you think there's always this role of
religion as being
in his broad definition religion as
being a complement to our sort of very
rigorous empirical pursuit of
understanding reality
there's always going to be this coupling
we'll always define
redefine new eras of civilization of
what
that religion actually looks like so you
talk about technology and so on being
the modern
set of religious uh beliefs around that
is so is that always going to is religio
is religion always going to kind of
cover the space of things we can't quite
understand with science yet
but we still want to be thinking about
oh i see what you're saying that's a
great question
when you say religion i would i would
use the word religiosity
uh because i think that we're moving out
of the dogmatic types of religions
into more of a i hate to put it this way
but an x-files type religion where we
can say
i want to believe or the truth is out
there
right but we don't know that it's out
there or we don't we don't know yet
what it is but we know it's out there so
there's this um this kind of built-in
um capacity for belief and something
that we don't have evidence for
yet and that's a sort of faith so i
would
say yes to that question absolutely i
think it's adaptive in that way
we're moving into a new i mean heck
we've already moved into this culture
most people have not caught up with it
yet i see that in the school systems
you know and i think that um i'm hoping
we can
catch up fast because really it's moving
faster than we are
you